We all have those things that grab our
attention, things that stick with us
quite often those things are abstract [Music]
But when I grow tired of numbers and symbols
there's one thing that I
keep coming back to [Music]
the camera keeps me grounded in reality
to really be mindful and see the world
and this campus not only for what it is
but for what it could be. To capture the
poetry in the things that we walk by every day
A Century of yearbooks by Technique
have inspired me along the way
and to give back and so I joined only to findsome things fell through the cracks after thepandemic,
no more office, no official home for
the gear and computers we lend out,
nowhere for the old books except a dark room condemnedfor asbestos. I really don't know what I'm doing
but I feel like we could bring it all back if
we could get the name out there again and keep
on taking photos and sharing the joy in lookingat things just that little bit more carefully [Music swells]
Technique faces challenges but whateverhappens I hope we can get people to think
of the Institute not just as a place
to work, but as an infinite canvas